So now that we have bars and
edges in V1,
we can go upstairs a little bit to V2.
And people do all sorts
of work of looking at
different types of patterns
that cause different effects.
And so some of the patterns were
based upon, like, little gratings and
shapes and swirls and things like that.
And sometimes, they were just on
these types of edges and things.
And, in Dave Van Essen's lab,
and, David,
a very well known neurophysiologist.
But when you look at things like this,
it's,
it's a little difficult to understand,
you know,
exactly how this is moving upstream
in the computational world.
We understand the need for edges.
And then you could maybe make some
argument about circles and, or,
curved parts.
One might say that, oh, you know,
what I'm seeing is stuff that
may be dealing with some types of
intersections or those kinds of things.
But the neurophysiologists, they keep
looking to understand what sorts of
images or low level features
will cause re cells to respond.
Going upstairs even
a little bit further,
there's an area called
the inferotemporal cortex.
And Tanaka did a lot of work on
looking at different kinds of features
that seemed to have cells that have
a strong response to these and
not other kinds of things.
And the idea was that maybe these
are where cells are starting to put
things together, okay.
And I, I guess one of the most
well known examples actually came
it was earlier and, you know,
the dates go different.
There was this so-called hand neuron,
okay.
And what this was is, this is a neuron
that when you showed it a picture of
a hand, it would fire a lot, and
the front of a hand, the back of a hand.
A, remember, these are kind of
like line drawings of hands, and
even this one and, and that one,
so different size scale.
But what was interesting is,
if you had an image that just
had this little spokes there,
it doesn't look like a hand to me,
it doesn't look like a hand to you.
Well, obviously, it didn't look
like a hand to this cell either.
And the idea that this was a cell.
Now, you might wonder what this picture
of this person looking like is.
Well, there was this whole
conversation of what was called,
did we find the grandmother cell.
That is, can you find a cell that just
fires when it sees my grandmother?
And I think this was
just a play on that.
But on the one hand, it was kind of
cool that you would find a single cell
that was responding to, say, just hands.
On the other hand, we know for a lot of
reasons that it can't be as simple as,
you know, there's a one for
one mapping between concepts and
cells, because there's all sorts of
reasons why that would be a bad design.
But we're getting at this idea that
what's being processed is no longer just
very simple features, but
something like, you know, this,
which is obviously a collection
of features in a useful way.
To further point that out,
here's two pictures of what you and
I would say are approximately same size
silhouette of a rhinoceros and a lion.
And these look sort of similar in
terms of where the stuff is, okay, but
of course they're different animals.
And what's nice is that in V1
these trigger similar cells.
So it's like cells that are responsive
to the, the edges in this location,
because the edges are sort
of in the same spot.
But of course,
they respond differently in IT.
IT is inferotemporal cortex.
You know, the idea is that maybe in
the cortex is a cell that understands
something about rhinoceros, so
it won't respond when it sees a lion.
And in fact, you can further confirm
that by showing it, if you find a cell
that sees lions but not rhinoceros,
now you show it two different pictures.
One that's a line drawing of a lion,
and the other one a much smaller
filled-in silhouette of a lion.
These objects in some sense look
different at the picture level, but
they are the same thing.
And unlike the previous pictures
where they are different things but
similar at the picture level,
these respond very differently in V1,
the early processing, and then there are
the same in the inferotemporal cortex.
So the idea being that higher up
are cells in the vision system that
understand something about
the appearance of object types.
At least, that's the, that,
that sort of the, the story.